[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push way
[Music]
welcome to a very special episode of
fight night flashbacks because eric i'm
here to fill you in on one of the
biggest
baddest
upcoming fighters in the ufc in quite
some time my man it might it's my job to
make sure
you know you're becoming an expert i i i
i'm a little bit
taken aback because he don't look like
well i understood
don't let the looks fool you okay
because what you're showing me is like
already with his looks and the name
daddy the baddie i feel you so just give
me some uh give me some background let
me give you some background some insight
here so patty the baddie he's with the
ufc now um
and he fights this saturday in uh ufc
london it's a fight night ufc london but
patty the baddie he's he's been on food
truck
he is the closest thing we currently
have to the next conor mcgregor so he's
from liverpool he's so famous there
and this isn't you're gonna have to they
call him the fifth beatle
come on man
that's what you're dealing with you're
telling me you're telling me it's the
beatles and then patty the baddie right
there
dude exactly okay exact same haircut
liverpool needs more stuff going on i
know dude i know so
he he's interesting because when he was
young you know these new kids now like
these these young fighters it's not like
with me it was like you know the ufc was
around since 93 but you'd start with
wrestling or whatever he started with
the the the goal of being in the ufc
right so when he's in high school yeah
so it's interesting so when he was in
high school
you know he got kicked out for for
fighting he would sell like chips and
candy and stuff to pay for his training
and actually kicked him out of school
wait he sold chips and candy and now if
you're in uh liverpool you call it crisp
crisps
wine gums so we sold stuff you could
just go down to the market and get yeah
but it's right there
you don't hate the hustle you know
that's all you would sell
maybe he was selling freaking hot beetle
albums
just the fifth beatles okay but let me
ask a question this is interesting
though because like i never thought of
it like that too this is like the new
generation of people in the same way
that kids today are growing up they have
cell phones and internet and social
media and my generation we didn't have
that right so so this kid grew his
to have the dream to be in the ufc
so you know and then
you hear a lot of stories about fighters
they start in the streets and they were
brawling and they had a bad childhood
yeah or they just had a wrestling
background a boxing background now this
kid it was like oh no straight mma so
i'm gonna be good at everything yeah so
he goes in the gym and to pay for his
training and selling chips and candy and
stuff like in high school they actually
kicked him out of high school for for
this hustle and he goes well my goal is
to be in the ufc and they all laughed at
him now that same high school and we're
going to watch a fight after he won the
cage warriors belt which is a big deal
over in europe cage warriors like conor
mcgregor came out there uh dan hardy
michael bisping a lot of big boys coming
out of their time
like monsters come out of there so
that's like their hotbed so he was the
face of that so once he became champion
his high school that kicked him out was
like oh can you come speak to the kids
right rename the gym yeah
yeah
the patty jam yeah
yeah patty patty gymnasium there's some
[ __ ]
but yeah he is i'm he this kid so you'll
see now we'll watch his fights and even
though you know you're not a hardcore
fan
this is his first fight dude this is
first fight he looks
13 here yeah man this guy looks like
what's going on in liverpool i think
this is 2012. is that right mike 2012 i
think it was his debut
patty pimblett patty pimlick patty the
baddie does he have like one of those
great accents too oh the best you want
as far as like entertaining bro you know
i've done a million food trucks he's the
only guy i've ever had on who he does a
promo and usually you know guys that do
that but most of them just talk to me
he goes where's my camera i'm like uh
there he goes looks into the camera and
does it end like a wwe dude
all these kids like randy macho man
savage yes
you know what he looks like you know he
looks confident
his stance is very these are like little
kids fighting he's our young boys
fighting yeah around wow kevin spacey's
like what is this um
oh he hit him with a slam
yeah so his his whole thing too is like
he'll talk a lot of trash
and he'll it's very similar to connor
where obviously there's an entertaining
aspect to it and he knows this can get
traction
but at the same time too one of the
reasons he's so big
is because
you can tell he actually believes it you
know what i'm saying like some guys you
listen talking like bro no i'm not i'm
not a big into fighting and i don't know
a lot about fighting but i i'm into this
energy and this guy is very much
in charge of whatever's happening right
now yes you know what i mean like his
like
his like demeanor and like the way he's
like uh
like how he stalked him right there this
is like why are they making out
especially especially that's side
control but especially for his first
fight and then also
his kind of x factor he's good on the
feet he's wild uh so it's hard to train
for him but his x factor is his
grappling is like world class look at
this when you're young like this just i
don't know if people should be watching
this you know when they're younger
you i wouldn't let my kid do it there's
no limber
what do you think's worse letting your
kid play like pop warner football or
this this 100
yeah yes this
this because how old are they right here
yeah he's young
did they just happen in the states no
this this is in liverpool so they don't
do this here
uh no there's kids doing it here there's
a there's a kid oh they gotta stop just
fighting oh yeah but here's the thing
eric in in early mma especially like
early pro when guys are like 100 2-0
there's a very
distinct difference on who's actually
going to be able to do this as a career
and who needs to go get a job yeah this
this kid here is done yeah like that kid
had no idea he's fine he's never
looking look at his face he's like what
the hell what the hell is that this one
i signed up for little did he know he
was fighting some a kid who's
like this is his only goal this is like
that guy looks like your second fight
remember
yeah he does yeah we're like yeah at his
face that's not snowflake that's not
stuff like that he's yeah look at his
face
oh [ __ ] what am i doing here yeah
fighting's fun to get beat up
you know it's all fun and games
i knew that's why i never yeah
he's seventeen yeah seventeen which is
to to pro debut like look how young he
is dude no but i just but even the
confidence there like when you don't
have anything it's everything dude yeah
he's very confident and this was his
first fight first pro fight yeah i think
he knew too oh good for him though i
like how he's not taking it too like uh
serious oh good for him get it yeah okay
look at he he's a showman
like like right off the bat the way he
just grabbed these two tricks like hey
okay and these are the old days where
anything went you had like fleshlight as
sponsors and condom depot and [ __ ] you
know
oh really find out he's 27 now yeah so
dude that's damn there 10 years ago so
that was his basically his first
professional man but you can tell like
the swagger there damn and then his
first professional fight before you play
this mike so this one so this cage wars
which in
uh in england is a big deal
so this is when he won the belt and cage
warriors again uh conor mcgregor came
out of there hardy michael bisping
aspinall like monsters come out of there
this kid was such a massive star then
his manager who is the owner of cage
warriors was saying he goes listen you
know i helped connor get to where he's
at i felt hardy bismilling we've never
had a bigger star than patty penny he
goes he can't walk down the street
what's interesting about this is
so he won the belt here the ufc has been
coming after him for
three or four fights before this and he
would turn it down because he made more
money fighting this than he would coming
over the ufc because ufc doesn't why not
and why not just be famous where you are
too you know if he's if he has i
understand feeling like feel the love of
your people and you're and you're making
a bunch of money you're famous it's like
yeah i guess he wants to ride his own
ticket but he eventually did come right
yeah the ufc eventually said well so
we'll get to that i'll get to that after
this fight because okay let me ask you
this is a big deal but his whole thing
was like i'm making money like i'm
making more money fighting cage warriors
why was something you see and eventually
his manager was like dude listen
like i know you're making all this money
here but in order to get to where you
want to get i know up front you're not
going to make as much money but the
potential is
yeah
let's take a little break from chatting
about patty pimlet with my friend eric
griffin because guess what man
i'm talking you fellas out there you
guys got bushes
they're pretty uh pretty gnarly bushes
out there and if you got one you need to
try the best products from my friends at
manscape that's right taking control of
your bush is important just ask your
girl or your mans
these products are so good you're going
to be showing pride in your new bush
free yard it's a fact that you will have
the best kept nut sack on the cul-de-sac
save big and be the most hygienic
version of yourself by using the code
shob20 sch aub20 for 20 off
and free shipping at manscape.com
all right you guys need to get this
package baby the manscape is dedicated
to you leveling up your full body
grooming care the grooming package which
is uh what i use and which i recommend
is the performance package 4.0 inside
this glorious package is the lawnmower
4.0 the electric trimmer you've heard
about it your bush is terrified of it
it's the best on the market comes with a
light do in the dark if you're weird all
right this trim is designed to reduce
grooming accidents and shave hair on
loose skin thanks to ceramic blade and
advanced skin safe technology all right
second best two in the performance
package is the weed whacker this is a
fine-tuned nose and air hair trimmer
listen if you have hair hanging out your
nose and ears
you're single all right i'm helping you
fellas out here man that's all i'm
trying to do i help i give back pay it
forward the performance package comes
with a crop reviver the crop preserver
ball deodorant spray-on testy toner dude
what also with the performance package
you get two free gifts the shed travel
bag and the high performance reduce
chafing manscape boxers which i love get
20 off and free shipping with the code
shop20 sch aub20 at manscape.com
getting into the u.s market is huge i
mean that's why musicians do it
comedians do it even even though i don't
care how big they are where they are
they want to come and get this the
united you know the 3 400 million people
here but also if you're a fighter like
there's other organizations but
if you're not in the ufc yeah it's kind
of you know what i'm saying it's like do
you want to be the best quarterback in
the cfl right
you know i'm saying is that gigan hoes
the answer is no maybe in a small
hometown but if you want to
internationally yeah you want to go
right so um that was his first fight he
was 17. what fight is this and how old
is he
man this is probably
because this is going to be
the belt
he's 21 here so how many fights have he
had up to this point
because now he must be like
has he lost yet he lie yeah yeah he has
yeah yeah which is not unusual in the uk
no
mma yeah and also it's different than
boxing like coming up even lost it's
like all good dude yeah you know it's
different than boxing all right hit it
oh
yeah
you see you see that yeah yeah yeah see
the fifth beatle
yeah you see what we're talking about
but you could you could just see how
he's like he's got his hair he's like
oh man and again that's what's
interesting so
he can he sold out that or it's an arena
in liverpool he sold that out himself
so he was selling out arenas even before
he came to the ufc so the ufc was like
hey man here's a basic contract and he's
like well i'm already selling out and
they're like you got to start somewhere
so you know he signed the deal even
though in his first fight ufc london
sells it out and his manager's like dude
we're selling out on our own yeah we
don't need all these ufc promo like yeah
yeah
he's
look at him
wow look how big he is how how little is
this guy this is featherweight title but
again if you uh go back to my food truck
insert video here you'll see he's 200
some pound in between fights he's funny
because he blows up like most fighters
like to keep it like maybe 10 to 15
pound range so if you're fighting at 55
you might walk at 170. even 180 would be
high homeboy walks at 200 plus how tall
is he
this is featherweight title yeah
145 yeah
it looks like shaggy from scooby doo
yeah
yeah liverpool shaggy yeah
he looks menacing though he's a big dude
yeah for the division he's big
he's really big i don't know if i don't
know if i like his bangs but i get it
for the but dude what a marketing play
there yeah i wonder if he meant to do it
or in liverpool does their hair just
grow like that because the beatles are
show well i mean it's like he he's very
like what a character just his hair is a
character you know what i mean he's got
a funny name he's like you know his you
know he's great at this fighting
obviously so i get it i mean i get it
i'm telling you we have to show erica
cliff like this kid is undeniable but
this doesn't look like this guy should
even be in this fight with somebody like
any time i see someone bigger versus
someone a little smaller it just i don't
know maybe that's just my ignorance of
not being like in the future
god
just rocked you jesus christ okay
champion and look how nuts the crowds go
i mean look at this dude nuts
nuts yeah he's
wow
just like that you win the belt
a few wine gums tonight from my man
there that's a big deal
no i mean i get it fighting over in
england like to be the cage warrior
champions like big deal big big deal oh
he now he's jumping on every yeah but
i'm saying i'm saying he very much like
he gets it you know what i mean oh i'm
telling you i've never come across
someone who gets it more than this kid
oh look at first at first i kind of
didn't get it and then once you get them
in person like oh this kid's special
yeah look at him he's just looking at a
crowd with like does he even know these
people this is just fans this is peeps
liverpool's finest good for him he's got
like a good energy man you you root for
this guy you know that's what i said
like some people might take it as
arrogance i'm like no it's not that
because he's so fun and playful and he's
light-hearted and he doesn't you know
there's no like uh like there's no venom
in his in his words it's just more like
fun here's my theory though here's my
thing
if you i don't think anyone could be
great
without arrogance i agree that has to be
a bit of an argument there has to be a
bit of like you have to feel like you're
the master of the universe is that his
kid no is it brother
probably
let's hope
um wow yeah this is like but anyway that
guy i do feel that i mean if you look at
like you ever hear michael jordan talk
you ever you know you know tiger woods
tiger woods you these people like
they're they have like
there's a delusionalness that they have
to have to achieve this kind of
greatness so i never worry about
arrogance i mean the difference between
let's say so what's the difference
between like him and conor mcgregor
because mcgregor seemed to like be
playing into this sort of bad boy thing
and then he's like throwing you know
throwing dollies at people and like
trying you know i think it's a different
level of life that was a different level
so connor there was a similarity with
patty where it was like this organic
like it was just part of their dna
they're entertaining
the words that they said came to
fruition and then somewhere along the
lines connor kind of went dark with it
yeah he was gonna notice too much yeah
that's too much and then
he lost a little bit of the support from
you know
ireland like it was just and then you
know him throwing the dolly with khabib
um hurting other fighters that's a big
no-no yeah and then also like you know
hitting the the man in the in the bar
right right but don't you think that do
you think that a lot of that has to do
with him like getting older and it's
like you've you know your talent it
doesn't last forever and just trying to
stay relevant and he chose that path
yeah i think there's that and then i
also think um
you know i i think too if you're conor
mcgregor and you know you sell your
whiskey company for whatever 400 million
dollars and you're making all the money
in the ufc and you made 150 million for
the floyd mayweather fight you're not
surrounded by people who are going to
hold you accountable so when you do that
stuff they're probably like damn that
was crazy man
where if it was one of us like
yes man yeah if i was like what the [ __ ]
what are you doing what are you doing
yeah yeah is this bad like it's awful
yeah yeah like this isn't the way to go
so connor went down a bad path
um i still root for him but i think it
for him it got dicey because he got too
much success and an mma too much success
kills you a little break from chatting
about paddy pimlet with my boy eric
griffin this one's gonna be quick for
you man you gotta protect your home you
gotta protect your home turf you don't
want anybody coming in there your home
needs to be the safest place on earth
and everybody deserves that that's why i
recommend simply safe home security
simply safe is advance whole home
security that puts you your home and
your family safety first here's why i
love it all right simply safe offers
comprehensive protection not only
against intruders and burglars but
against expensive home hazards from
flooding to fires with 24 7 professional
monitoring simply safe agents take
action the moment the threat is detected
all right they're dispatching police or
first responders in emergency even if
you're not home they're making sure your
crib is safe man simply safe uses video
verification technology so that
monitoring agents can visually confirm
the threat in order to get higher
priority on the 911 dispatch all right
monitoring plans are affordable they're
priced at a dollar a day with no
long-term contracts or hidden fees none
of that stuff because feeling safe at
home shouldn't break the bank you can
customize your perfect security system
for your crib in just minutes at
slash simplysafe.com that's s-i-m-p-l-i
safe dot com slash shob for twenty
percent off
this episode of flashback fight nights
with patty pimlet near griffin is also
brought to you by
happy hippo listen kratom
is the wild west out there you don't
know who to trust like cbd back in the
day but now cbd is pretty damn good well
happy hippo kratom is gonna be right
there because you can trust happy hippo
i use kratom for everything stand up
podcasting life workouts you name it
your boy dinners that i'm bored of tears
in i'm dropping knowledge on folks
because i'm all hopped up on great em
that that's my limitless bill kratom but
not just any kratom happy hippo kratom
and if you visit happy
herbles.com use promo code sickboy for
20 off you get it for life you use that
code as many times as you want to try
the best kratom on the frickin planet
that's happyhippo
herbals.com use promo code sickboy for
20 off for life let's get back to the
program is there a world where uh this
kid would fight conor mcgregor
oh conor connor's big right now so for
him to come to 55
and i think they're two should be
sailing through the night because
connor is looking for these like mega
fights and then our boy patty is coming
up so patty right now even though
top ten most famous guys in the ufc
experience and talent-wise not top ten
has a that like has work to do oh so
you're saying let's go straight to the
ufc you say mcgregor would beat him
right now yes right now
you know depending too like what version
of connor are we going to get because
you know conor uh snapped his leg so
he's rehabbing his leg but you know
connor's talking about fighting like
michael chandler nate diaz or charles
oliveira so he's like at a certain level
where the only upside here would be for
patty not conor you know if connor
wanted to throw him a bone and it'd be a
massive [ __ ] fight in europe but in
america like don't get wrong patty's big
but he's not conor in america not
liverpool across the seas
so they did it over there would be huge
now you know what's interesting about
watching these fights like this like
these time jumps is like
like look how you see him grow up yeah
like look like look how serious that he
is it looks like his face is taking a
little bit of a beating too you know
what i mean i mean rightfully so yeah
all that she's not punching the face
can't
but
forever the cuteness is wearing off yeah
some of that the kid vibe is out of here
you know what i'm saying yeah he went
from like backstreet boys to like you
know
yeah like yeah he should be on king of
the stage
so this is his first ufc fight right
right
okay so he's ready so again comes over
to the ufc decides to take a pay cut but
in hopes he'll knock out a few like one
or two or maybe right really one or two
guys and then come with ufc like yo man
all right played your game i took a pay
cut but now you gotta pay me
um what do you think about did should he
have taken the pay cut
um it's tough because the ufc is going
yeah you're picking cage warriors but it
ain't the ufc
you know so
it's it i get it and i always think the
fighters should be paid more but if
again i i i stopped talking about the
the money situation on the ufc because i
don't know right i don't know what their
overhead is i don't know what the daily
overhead is and the fighters and how
much income they're have like we get
reports oh biggest year ever it's like
okay cool when you look at how much how
many fighters on the roster the staff
all the endorsement deals espn
everything that goes into it i don't
know i know the fighters could
definitely be paid more but i don't know
the yeah it's like someone talking about
my business like i know but they're not
getting like uh like an nba nfl
you know
no no no i'm talking about like you know
like i believe that the in the nba the
salary structure works where the that
players are getting like 48 percent of
that's almost 50 50. yeah so mlb so but
remember nba you're talking about 12
players a team no i i understand that
but regardless of that regardless that
they're still splitting like you know
five billion dollars a lot of money so
what i'm saying is i don't know what the
ufc is making but i doubt that they're
that the the fighters are getting fifty
percent of the property it's seventeen
percent okay so
i think they got as high as 20 but i
think it's usually in general 17. but
this guy like is so let me this is an
other question because i'm so stupid
about this kind of stuff but like so is
it one of these things where the ufc is
only in the united states no okay you'll
see it's massive everywhere okay so then
i think i i think he should have been
like
hey you have to come fight and
we're i'm gonna take a ufc fight but it
has to be in liverpool which is what
they did you know they brought to
liverpool and
again
at first
how much money you're making just the
gate he bet on himself so let's see if
he bet on himself he's in the ufc you're
going to fight tougher competition like
the conference in the ufc is going it's
going to be tough man
and the other thing you think the ufc is
the top oh not even close yeah not even
close but also ufc is the big leagues
but also with the ufc
and i i i get part of this too they're
gonna go we get it cage wars is great
you sell out but you're not fighting at
this level it's a different game prove
yourself and and we're willing to
negotiate with you earlier than any
other fighter but just let's make sure
that you can compete over here like he's
on a rookie deal there you go and his
rookie deal i think only asked what two
fights three fights like nothing so
let's see this is the first one yes oh
he is focused
now i want you to notice something
though see
that guy looks different than the guy
you saw him fight last time yeah and the
big leagues
wow look but he's still wait a minute
he's still huge but that's his advantage
his height his advantage at 55. god damn
how tall i forgot if you said how tall
is he god was he probably six oh
man this this is a menacing
five times oh man this is a menacing i
feel like he's taller than that
gee whiz man
i'll give him at least six foot when i
stand next to the kid maybe it's just
his hair
definitely bigger than 510. so this guy
it's his movement look how big his legs
are who's this guy is this guy the other
guy is he like a big deal at the time
he's in the ufc okay so if you get to
the ufc like you're a champion and
somebody but it feels like wwf like he's
one of the weekly losers that you know
what i mean well he's not like a world
beater like this guy's you know he's not
going to be a world champion over in the
ufc but we've got him yeah see that's
what i want you to notice you'll see in
all his fights that's why i told him
he gets tagged there oh but he tagged he
took it yes
and he got taken down
oh yeah so he's definitely bigger than
599
that was a vicious hit that he just took
but you see why the ufc again this is
going to be his toughest competition
your first fight outside so you're
saying you think at this point in his
career this is the toughest fight he's
ever fought by far okay by far even
though he came from you know a quality
organization cage warriors the ufc
because this guy he was brazilian or
some [ __ ] he probably got whatever leak
he came from he was the champion there
yeah yeah you know so you can be
championing these other smaller leagues
but again it ain't the ufc man
but you see with patty we're gonna watch
what two ufc fights three
one more you'll see there's a common
theme where his naysayers
and i've even brought this up on food
truck he gets hit
he does get hit and what he told me he
goes my coaches know this
i get hit to feel the fight and it wakes
me up i said i'm cool with that right
now but as you start fighting tougher
guys and you can't get him yeah like if
that's what you need to wake up i know
get hit in the back yeah like get hit
you you experience that you know you get
hit it's like
sometimes you don't you think you you
know then you you know
especially at heavyweight but even wrong
but him at 55 like there's some guys at
55 like you don't want to get hit by
physique early on you know what i'm
saying like you don't you can't take
those changes that's true so this is
lightweight yeah one thing because
you're in a heavyweight heavyweight yeah
oh jesus christ totally different you
don't get any mulligans
you know what i'm saying
there's no mulligans yeah you said i'm
awake already yeah now we're good see
it's hit again so again the naysayers
are like oh dude he's getting hit but oh
[ __ ] he chooses to do this like this kid
that's the other thing about ufc you
know especially early on
none of these guys are scared you know
what i'm saying like everyone's game
they all come they're a champion their
own dude this dude right here the other
dude okay this but this other dude must
be like why isn't this guy going down
correct i mean i think it's weird he's
gotten so many hits in look at him you
could tell he's like uh oh i gave him my
best but also remember this eric is you
only get so many punches to the face
there's a it's a clock it's a countdown
so
if he's gonna take whatever he's taking
four or five here all right let's say
you have a hundred told in your career
all right that's five off now my man oh
you get 100. before you before the you
get they call it your chin goes you only
get a certain amount of hits and some
fights really you know certain guys you
know you look at uh stipe jds you've got
kane jds some fight or tony ferguson uh
justin gaichi some of these fights just
take it out of you you never come back
the same fighter oh this this this guy's
got good he's got a good jab yes because
he's keeping him he's keeping him away
with this jab it should be noted
fantastic tan
i mean he's a good looking dude you know
what i mean oh yeah no doubt
oh he's he was setting up for something
oh
yeah and you know pat again he's special
on the ground if he can get him down
but
the british when it comes and like
people from that area
europe in general the wrestling isn't as
good as america or like you guys from
russia or dagestan
gotcha it's just oh oh oh oh oh oh
i'm telling you this this other guy has
been worried
since
he gave him his oh
that's it that's it you're done that's a
big feather in the cap there you're done
but again if if you're if you're a paddy
like
critic you're going hey you got hit
didn't get him out that's enough no
listen listen to me i'm not a fight guy
but i'm watching this entertaining and
right but the thing is like i said that
other guy
that other guy gave him his best oh yeah
in the middle of that fight and he
didn't go down and you could tell the
other guy was like oh oh
and then he he his whole demeanor
changed that other guy's demeanor was
like i'm in trouble yeah man
i
felt that
this guy's dead for a debut it's fun
he's just excited he's fun i think what
makes him also so
what makes him so kind of must-see tv is
he does get a little wild like he does
get hit he does get taken down like it's
just not this like khabib or connor
dominant dominic styles starching dudes
like he's a bit of a fisticuffs
oh that was it right there that one that
was that man that was it yeah
and then he just unloaded yeah now he's
just waiting for the guy to finish it
stop the fight he just he now probably
tell him you better stop it fool you
better stop it now that's his training
partner and her name's uh meatball oh
jesus and she's a female fighter from
the same place okay
her name is meatball yeah i'm fantastic
nickname she's also fun but so with
patty look at that six million views
dude so many people watch that his first
fight uh just on that so patty does that
right and then bar stool who sponsors
certain guys goes hey they make
announcement that they're gonna sign
paddy to seven figure deal barstool is
seven figure deal patty what does this
first thing manage him or something or
what do they do no they just use them
for content and he's like their guy wow
good for him
interesting right yeah so so he gets a
seven figure deal from barstool now the
reason why that's important is because a
lot no one else has to deal with
barstool really right or you get these
huge endorsements but this kit is so
entertaining and just has the it factor
our stool goes all right we're gonna pay
seven figures well where it gets dicey
for the ufc is
the ufc will go
all right man this guy got injured fight
this guy in two weeks notice and the
fighters usually need the money like not
the best oh not him not and then him i
go because again he blows up in between
fights yeah yeah so on food truck i go
what are you gonna do if they actually
do a short notice fight man like you're
220 pounds there's no way you're gonna
cut what is it [ __ ] 70 pounds so you
called it right basically yeah basically
it's coming from me you know what i'm
saying yeah anyway hey fatty yeah patty
the fatty
yeah
yeah but what's interesting is i go with
that you take a short notice fighting
started laughing he's like i'm not that
you know shortening his fight you know
how much money i make not fighting good
for him more money not fighting he's
probably counting down when he have
never has to fight again yeah he was
like i'm in no rush he's like doing
anything that's going to [ __ ] my career
wow there's two guys that have that
power it's like kim and then sugar shawn
o'malley where they don't have to do
anything well good for this guy yeah so
this is what fight is this is his last
fight mike
so he's had so how many ufc fights did
he have between that first one and this
one
yeah so his first official ufc fight was
at the apex center in in the ufc and
that's the apec center is on the ufc
property and it's not a massive crowd
it's maybe 300 people oh wow so what i
like for the ufc for his first fight
they're like all right let's try this
out fight the apec center and then pass
that test and then we're going to get
this
rolling so then the next look at that i
think that's kind of like i don't like
how the ufc was trying to like make him
feel like he's not big you know i think
they were trying to not pay him like
they were trying to get upset let's keep
him like that's let's let's slow your
roll there's that but then also they've
had guys like darren till and other
fighters with
sage northcutt that they throw the
[ __ ] gamut to and like you're ready
for everything and then it doesn't work
gotcha so i think it's gfc going
has a lot of potential let's start slow
pass that test then we're off to the
races and after the races ufc london 02
arena it's his crowd so again his
manager's like dude we sold again we
sold this exact rin out on our own
several times okay let me ask you this
though so he's familiar with this one
let me ask you this so other ufc
fighters they watch this kid i mean when
you guys are watching i mean is there a
certain level where the the ufc like
looks down on those other leagues or oh
yeah when they look at this they think
like who's this kid and that kind of
thing or there's a lot of jealousy same
with comics right like you see comics
doing theaters and selling out like well
why is he selling i'm not i know why is
that guy getting attention
my career who are you in my career
by comics i mean every comic i've ever
met anyways uh
haters gonna hate that [ __ ] british show
but with patti same thing though because
they're rolling out the red carpet for
him now yeah yeah and fighters like you
know
i think patty has all the potential in
the world to be world champion but he's
not there yet so if you're in the top 15
this kid's getting all this attention
and you probably know you could beat him
because he's not there yet he's going to
get there i feel something so so they're
going to be like bro what i'll fight
that guy in the news he's like that
ain't happening wait wait he makes his
money you don't i feel some doubt
that you're saying about him about his
skills what's he lacking
uh i don't like uh if you watch
a lot of his fights and again i've said
this to his face i don't like that he
gets hit gotcha got you guys you know
what i'm saying like to me that's
trouble but to his defense he goes
that's on purpose man like i like to get
in that i like to feel the fight i like
to get it wakes me up then i know i'm in
a fight and i went right now
all good okay
okay 20 something year old yes okay
bubba with your 30 bro okay but what uh
but other than that what so you say you
don't like just experience um
uh yeah i
yeah the fundamentals as far as defense
goes i think if grappling's up to
parking compete with anybody he just has
to pass certain levels of the game
before he gets there i'm fully on board
he just has to do work like this
weekend's gonna be a bigger test for him
um it's you know tough guys probably
fought so
there's just levels to it before i go
yep next champion i'm not willing to do
that yet i think he has all the
potential he checks every [ __ ] box
yeah
i feel like uh you think that
he's gonna take a hit that he's not
gonna recover from correct if but but
also
yes there's that but then also i think
what makes him special is he he his
fight iq is very high and i think he's
going to realize like oh i can't keep
doing this he's going to adapt you hope
so i hope so all right i believe so so
it's the second fight let's see this one
the second fight
he's always still focused at the start
of the fight man real quick before you
play this so he's not even the main
event he's the third fight on the main
card right
but this fight is so like everyone's
there for him
everybody is there for him like this is
why everybody came and he's not the main
event yet yeah see again make your main
event i got a problem with that i'm with
you you know what i'm saying especially
if i'm him i'm like bro that'd be like
that'd be like somebody's coming to see
the opener you know like you're you're
headlining yeah and every and
everybody's like
for the opener like when you get on like
right it's like and we and the club
knows it too yeah and the club knows it
so they're like you know it's like i
don't like that
i don't i don't like that
all right
who's this conflicting character
yeah this guy we can see pat the other
thing i like about patty is why if he's
a stock i'm gonna invest is every fight
he's getting better see he gets hit
there he gets hit there well he was
trying to get he's going straight back
he got hit
on the ground too
but a lot of this you know if people
they get taken down early they get hit
a lot of fighters with you know this new
to the ufc with the ufc experience a lot
of them it messes with the mentality but
again he has such a belief in himself
that he knows he's going to get out of
this and he's going to beat him this is
this is a this is a strong move right
here yes
this isn't ideal if you're a paddy fan
right now yeah
but again his advantage bigger for the
weight class taller rangier you know
how long do they let this go on this
little
until the guy on top or if the guy on
bottom can wrap him up they'll break him
up but if the guy on top stops trying to
advance if you just hold them down
they'll stand them up oh got you
i think it depends on the fighter too
like if it's like a khabib or a dominant
guy who's really good on top then you
let him
allow him more time before they stand up
there's two strikers they're like dude
get the hell up what are you two doing
well it looked like he just gave him a
little kiss on the neck
you know what i mean
like thanks man
i guess that's a way to get in
somebody's head i would say something to
him i would be in his ear like
i'm gonna eat your butthole boy
just to make him be like hey stop it
what are you talking about
yeah it depends on the fighter i'd like
yeah i'd start laughing like damn bro
that's the bonus this is fantastic dad
see that's the counter yeah that's right
there's gotta be there's gotta be
there's no or is it just all focus or is
there anything you're talking about
during a fight dude what's the worst
that anybody's ever said dude in the
middle of a fight bro i thought this guy
lavar johnson who is
you know he's done some time and
he and and he did fail the drug test
when i fought him so during the weigh-in
we pose off and i look at dana and
joseph i go bro he could finish [ __ ]
fourth in mr olympia he's there's no way
he's he's not going to not test hot and
i started laughing i'm like clearly on
steroids i'm still going to beat him so
i take him down over and over and he was
just a banger
he's part of a biker gang
went to prison i don't know if he's
still in prison went to prison for some
stuff recently um so where i keep taking
him down and he thought i was just gonna
brawl with him which is insane because i
can rest on grapple kept taking him down
and finally i take him down for like the
ninth time whatever and he goes bro let
me up let's bang bro this is [ __ ]
because this is [ __ ] he kept going
this is [ __ ] let's bang bro and i
said why don't you learn how to wrestle
oh yeah i was like once you learn how to
wrestle then we can bang
and then after i beat them right by
decision you know ten nines across the
[ __ ] board smoked them i'm in the
lobby with my uncle who passed away my
favorite uncle my brother and my dad are
there and uh him and his biker gang all
walks in i look at my brother hey head
on swivel get ready and i was like oh
they're going to be so mean to me and
his biker gang bros came up was like
that was fun man my boy needs to learn
how to wrestle though right
it was like yeah i was like oh thank god
oh my god thank you
oh so patty gets them down with that
dope ass hip toss yeah and then straight
to his back and this is where he's
special like his grappling is just
dynamic man he's long range because he's
so lanky
look at he can like he's like gumby he
can like wrap around that body lock
there wow
he's got his foot locked right there
that's it this is it he's going to give
up now remember if you tap out if you
pop out you have to go to sleep yeah
remember if you bought a ticket to this
fight and you're expecting patty to just
you know come out and guns are blazing
you haven't had a lot to celebrate so
this is a big deal and then they go nuts
look at the crowd nuts neither boy
when he comes up dancing oh man
there's meatball oh she's crazy
she fought earlier and was fantastic she
got the crowd rocking so the crowd's
there for him and her so after this it's
like asmr was the headliner who's the
next like big heavyweight out of london
she looks intense
oh look at him he's dana give me my
money [ __ ] yeah what are you saying to
him right now where's my money where's
my money you're gonna pay me now right
that's what he just said
look at his face like damn it i'm gonna
have to pay this kid yeah he is because
he actually negotiated a new deal now
are they after like two three fights are
these two having sex because it's
probably intense as hell i don't think
so can you imagine how yeah
he's had the same girlfriend since i
don't know oh okay ninth grade or some
[ __ ]
because those two it seemed like it
would just be like
you know what i mean like yeah
he would finish and be like
they just seem really intense oh this
guy can't believe look at him that look
on his face he can't believe he lost oh
wow that's it for that guy that guy
knows that that's it for him that the
other guy that this was his opportunity
yes that guy was he knows he's like damn
it i i'm i have to take a fight in two
weeks now yeah yeah right now he's one
of the two weak guys he's the guy that
you seem like well
great toss there and then you know he's
going a little eager to get the mount
there and he ends up in uh but then this
transition to his back is pretty filthy
yeah well he just look at his his
footwork
he's got good footwork huh great yeah on
the ground phenomenal phenomenal
well and this is only a second fight so
then his third fight's coming up
saturday
wow
now saturday is the first time i thought
to myself toughness i'm actually
interested in yes seeing seeing this
fight because there's nothing better in
sports i don't care what sport you're
into than the rise of a young prospect
in the ufc because it's just like you go
on this journey with them and they're
passing the test like the connor that's
why i vouched for connor dude
that when he was coming up and you know
i was doing uh at the time was the big
brown breakdown and he's coming up and
you're following like this kid out of
[ __ ] dublin man and then he becomes
this you know the biggest star to ever
[ __ ] do it it's it's just
nothing well dude i remember the rise of
ronda rousey oh i mean that was just
like that so that cap that captivated
the whole nation yep everybody was like
oh my god this and then
you know i mean yeah that's what and
that's why people are kind of like well
let's wait and see yep that's that's why
i i'm i'm never so this is who he's
fighting so let's see he's fighting next
this other guy this other guy jordan
levitt you know i call you is he a big
deal like i'm sweet and low he's not a
huge deal he will dance he doesn't have
some sugar in this tank it feels like
you know he's he's uh
you can't help but like the guy like
he's very nice and he's
he's he's patty's toughest test but also
it's a good fight for patty too it's not
like an impossible task okay but what
i'm saying though is like he's going to
finish him but what i'm saying but if he
doesn't that would be a huge loss for
his uh the rise you're talking about so
he has to win this fight this one it you
know in london again fight night they're
doing it on purpose is he the main event
now finally i know tom aspinall versus
uh curtis blades is what to be fair
though tom asked when i was ranked what
fifth and curtis plays like two in the
world okay so you know that the main
event should be the main event and tom
small is getting big but he's tom small
is different than patty where tom is a
heavyweight he's a little more reserved
doesn't like the spotlight so talented
though so talented uh so well this is i
like this kid
i'm telling you you're gonna be in the
patty patty the baddie patty the baddie
the fifth beatle in between the shows
he's the fatty
patty the baddie but if you don't have a
fight he's the fastest
that could be his podcast in between
fights in between fights with the fatty
he's just like yeah i got a burger and
like he's not gonna be able to do that
for much longer either yeah again that's
a young man that's what i'm saying so
you talked to like a tj dillashaw these
other guys like guys get 28 29 it's like
oh i gotta stay i gotta stay ready your
body's like oh we don't respond yeah
yeah yeah we gotta stay ready let's just
start with the big macs
yes at a certain point he's gonna have
to stay ready but again him doing that
stuff to me makes him more likeable
because of course you get done doing
something tough you want to go hard on
in the paint on the food
but there's money in people thinking
he's ready
and unbeatable like like right now i'm
not being professional yeah being
professional because that's what tj
dillashaw said tj goes i never get that
heavy because i'm a professional across
the board man like look at him here you
watch out watch how big he is next to me
look at him oh my god
that's my boy right now
any great
but he's the best oh man
if you met him you would love him you
would love him
is
hilarious how fat he is
and do and he got a second burger
how much longer we have he goes i love
doing this with you he goes but
liverpool's playing in an hour man i
don't want to miss that and he went to a
pub probably had some bears and more
[ __ ] burgers good for him watch
liverpool he
i'm telling you he's the best i'm
he is going to be a comfortable fat [ __ ]
okay he's just going to be like you know
probably your dad yeah you know what i
mean just being like people going to be
like you used to fight yeah
you're patty the baddy
i'm not even kidding i am i actually
want to watch this fight i want to see
this guy as uh i would like you were
saying the rise i want to see what he
does and look where this is at laugh
factory san diego oh wow yeah so we had
a food truck and i need to play sit down
so i hit up black factory san diego and
as you guys are watching this i'm at la
factory this week thursday friday
saturday at that very same location when
is this coming factory san diego this
comes out wednesday yeah it comes out uh
wednesday this is tomorrow yep yeah well
then look for me and i'm in austin texas
creek in the cave come and watch me yup
go get it eric we love you man thanks
man you're the best you ready the baddie
patty the baddie looking like a
[Music]
a fatty bit of work man that don't scare
us i get up i go hard like i'm george
harris make plays break lanes push break
chains go hard kick ass take names